and white welcome to this video playing
snuba yeah he's this very fast player
I'm not trying for all that much on the
bullet but difficult to play because
he's so quick i had this petrol of game
against in recently where this really
got to be a got to be an issue so let's
see this is a well-known line against
white set up where I think that like is
perfectly okay then I put it on the
board reasonably quickly so you have
this I hate on the board more than once
this caption there are a couple of
things I can also just play Bishop e7
which is probably right people don't
like bishops I don't know what they do
here they don't like bishops for some
reason why be nice to your bishops they
are strong anyway um this position is
not particularly Bishop friendly let's
say if we if there's a word like that so
it should see ate something that I think
is interesting but probably he will just
take however that was my that was my
attention mmm not so happy now that I
see it we can win d 5 which looks kind
of undesirable
maybe the smooth is first I was only
considering to him to to do it the other
way around like take first and it was
kind of stupid to refer to forget this
possibility okay so let's put this
vision on to you form yeah still not too
happy a queen age 386 those things I got
into this trouble because I forgot about
this possibility now maybe I should we
should see ADA what really why is that
good okay not not not okay let's take
this first okay okay just just wait for
one moment if I cheeky for you can take
here Queen takes my rook is hanging hmm
yeah anyway I mean he doesn't really
look for anything to substantial I mean
he could have thought about this was an
interesting position that this is just
nothing for white but you did this very
quickly which makes the dangerous from a
practical sense of course
so I can go to e1 tween f1 yeah or just
age 16 yeah so that I have King age 76
so here if I go look is six is there
something going on mmm should always
have enough counter players King is also
wide open so if he gives check cm ok so
is you just want to play this worst
ending or what's the deal let's see
maybe you can go talk aids and they have
to make a drawdown with the perpetual I
don't have more I think check
check I don't really don't really see
more this is the only thing that I see
that that continues which is of course a
bit risky because of the time situation
I'm just kind of stuck to that corn
g3 is its assets a bit of a threat I
mean g3 an h1 move Quincy to was made on
edge too so it's not completely nothing
that he can so easily ignore so what is
this month after g3 now the moves eh
porn I will just play Quincy to and win
right here's no check and h2 we cannot
come on I don't know I don't know
don't really see I mean maybe he just
lets me take that just kh1 or something
time morning this also G to hear but
this probably doesn't doesn't win i also
have rupee for in this position which is
probably useful right yeah that must be
useful moving
okay oh my winnings are em check 24 i
don't i don't really see how this winds
queen g5 queen g5 no ha now the bloody
time cat gets to be a factor again check
check check check game draw I'm terrible
my winning this is pretty terrible but
karen has the thing you just place like
very very quickly and i will get into
tram pressure somehow and then the
likelihood of something stupid is just
increasing I mean here I should just win
somehow so look g four winds Chuck yeah
this is wasn't yeah look g4 was thinking
I can't just also prevents the this
prevents the chicks and this is the
winning idea okay as something like that
I was very sure i had a win here but i
couldn't figure it out and if i invested
20 seconds or something I mean I'm just
losing I'm just losing I was thinking
this one but he has root g one and kind
of continues ok so if we check this game
I mean the objection I know I'm
complaining about those people who play
on time and like this is not about
playing fair or whatever it's about yeah
sometimes they just don't try to find
find good moves in good positions I mean
here my opponent has a great position I
mean quite clearly something has gone
wrong my original intention was this
move but I was getting a bit concerned
about this here if it turns out the
engine is pretty happy with my position
here at least I am Bishop a 6 Andrew
create now this position is a tad lose
them yep what I simply dislike for the
sake of good chances that they keep
continuing to blitz out anything instead
of trying to win a good position this is
just very good for white and instead of
trying to do something and you played
like this and then like 84 which can
only be worse for white I mean okay the
engine says it's okay for him but I mean
here you can try to figure something out
I'm in the check this is all very
interesting and it gets not played in
favor of something quickly here yet
Queen takes d3 oh my god Wow okay yeah
this is check check this is losing quite
clearly Wow and this is still somehow a
game I don't quite check check check why
actually okay have two pawns at least so
it's not like super easy but white white
should win yeah okay instantly 24 and
just traded everything down to
position quite clear only white can be
worse f5 is weak his king is weaker than
mine and so on and it yet it got very
much worse but I couldn't do it because
of the time which shows the upside of
playing instant Wilson of course ok guys
thanks for watching